foreign
says he has no sexual desire however as
time goes on I think he really does sex
is always just meant abuse and hate I
need that physical connection with him
this is the only piece of our marriage
that needs help it's a big piece
yo yo yo what up this is John the Dr
John Maloney show
so glad that you're with us the greatest
show ever
ever
talking about mental health
relationships
what's going on your sex life what's
going on in your parents oh we're
talking about everything what's going on
your kids schools you name it uh give me
a buzz and we'll figure it out together
if you want to be on the show give me a
shout
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 let's go to Shea in
Pittsburgh what's up Shay
hi Dr John
um right off the bat please know I'm a
super nerd and I've condensed this
complicated issue into several grouped
bullet points that I'm going to try to
get through as quickly as possible
because I'd really rather hear your
voice well thank you for thank you for
being a super nerd in our super nerd
gang that's super good
what your latest book is life-changing
and every night I ask
asking cards and have some amazing
conversations I'm going to jump into my
question right now there's no
compliments make you awkward so how can
everything makes me awkward Shay
everything
how can how can my husband and I start
working towards having a crazy fabulous
sex life when we're both prisoners of
our own mind and past and currently only
engage in obligatory sex once every few
months and okay so here come my detail
bullets all right let's do it my my
husband and his siblings
were horrifically physically and
sexually abused by a monster who was
also his biological father
my my husband says he has no sexual
desire however as time goes on I think
he really does it's just he's never been
in love before he's never had a loving
relationship and he's sex is always just
meant abuse and Hate
um oddly enough the more we talk about
this the more uncomfortable I feel
initiating because I'm learning more and
more how uncomfortable he is with sex
and selfishly I hate to initiate because
it makes me feel ugly and like a big old
man and no matter how many times my
husband reassures me he loves me and
finds me attractive it's just his
actions are speaking louder than his
words now Genesis I have to include
these historical bullets I'm sorry I'm
going as fast as no you hey hold on one
second take a big deep breath okay I'm
trying to read these like a secretary
like it's not my own issue so I don't
forget no I know I know you are you are
doing you're you're very courageous and
I could hear you hanging in there and so
thank you thank you take your time take
your time I'm in no rush I don't have
anything else going on today I'm just a
double YouTuber so I'm good well we my
husband and I we we met in kindergarten
we're friends forever lost touch we
reconnected uh 30 years later we married
and moved in together six years ago uh
after we had both gone through a divorce
we both had three children and we each
had one minor child still left at home
we we each had one daughter both the
same age
for four years for the first four years
of our marriage he would live with us
for 10 days and then travel five hours
up north to stay four days with his
minor daughter
for his visitation two years ago his
teenage daughter started going off the
rails and we had to have a come to Jesus
moment I don't know if I can say that
but we had to have a very difficult talk
and we made the decision that he needed
to move back up north until both of our
girls graduate which is thank God only
279 days from today
no not that you're counting right
right the past two years we only see
each other two uh sometimes four to five
days every month you had a very similar
call a while ago with a man the roles
were reversed and you recommended him
read the book Come As You Are by the way
can't ever get that book cover image out
of my head thanks for that
I started reading it but Dr John I had
to stop because it just seemed so
focused on the female who was having
trouble with sex and I just found it
very hard to translate because there
just seems to be something uniquely
cruel about the female in the
relationship not getting any that could
talk forever about that yeah okay so how
do we feel let me get you there that
book is written for two women about
women and so I actually take that book
out of context and I recommend Men read
it
um and so yes you're like it's it's
overwhelmingly female because it's Dr
nagoski wrote it to women right it's a
it's a letter to women uh I've just
found it super helpful for entertaining
the conversation like it
yeah anyway it's it's mind-blinding for
men and women
um but I can't I do get your point
um but that's that was actually the
point of it but okay go ahead yeah and
so as that said I I I've never talked
this is the first time I'm telling
anybody this other than my husband and
and so I figured I'd start by telling Dr
John Jenna Kelly and your mom and um so
how do we start having a crazy awesome
sex life and and of course I mean my
husband and me of course and yes please
be as direct and honest with me as you
can hit me where it hurts no I don't
know there's nothing to hurt here
um I'm heartbroken here with you
um
you told me a lot about your husband you
told me a lot about his past you told me
a lot about his daughter he told me a
lot about some hard decisions y'all had
to make in your marriage which is going
to be better generationally and long
term and all that
you've never told me what you want
what do you need what do you feel what
what's going on with you
[Music]
and hey you've never said these words
out loud before and you are someone who
loves your husband and probably have
taken on partly a maternal role for him
because you want to protect him from
getting hurt again like his evil father
did
and when you think I really want this or
if y'all are about to have sex and even
if it's just like y'all are about to
have sex and it's just get off sex right
it's just married couple let's just do
this sex and he quit
like you get angry and then you feel
guilty for getting angry or you get
frustrated and you get angry for getting
frustrated right so for the first time
what do you actually need what do you
want
I need that physical connection with him
it's like our marriage just is so
he is the perfect man for me
and I am the perfect woman for him
this is and I'm a bit of a perfectionist
and this is the only piece of our
marriage
that needs help
but it's it's a big piece
it's
awesome and I'm so excited but it's
getting to the point now where
so stressful like okay um am I going now
he when I initiate
he never stops me and you know
things are Mechanicals whatever and I
just
I want him to come on to me
like when I'm I've actually cut myself
off kind of socially for from
two of my girlfriends I have
plus who used to be close with me
because we used to talk about
you know we
women say things to each other like oh
your hubby's coming into town I I'm so
excited you're gonna get lucky
and uh you know and then they complain
about
their marriages and how annoying it is
that their husbands are constantly
coming on to them and I just want to
punch him in the face and I don't
but okay so let's let me back all the
way out here
um
when y'all first got married
was it hot and heavy or has it always
been stilted and awkward
it seemed to be hot and heavy in the
beginning okay and then as as we started
learning more about each other and he
started opening up more I started
becoming
more worried um there you go because I I
kept learning okay so let me stop you
right there okay you said earlier on
that
he maybe had never been in love before
and he's absolutely been in love before
he's probably had very few moments in
his life when his body felt truly safe
yes and he has a radar system on his
body for a lack of safety or for tension
or for
not with me or for using me
that you and I could never understand
it is a fine-tuned NASA built radar
system
and so he finds you and he's perfect for
you and you're perfect for him and then
he starts opening up and his body says
I'm safe with this one
it's never been safe and it's safe with
this one
and the more you learn the more your
body
starts feeling awkward or a little bit
weird or maybe just absolutely and I
know we're not allowed to say this out
loud
absolutely revolted disgusting
you know what I mean
and it's hard it's and then all of a
sudden like I I my your sexual desire
gets tangled up in his abuse the whole
thing is gets to be a mass and then you
stop talking a little bit or you make
your body gets a little bit tense when
he reaches over right and so it's just
it's it's by degrees
and then we land here what you've done
with your girlfriends I would tell you
is 100 exact opposite you know what both
of you are right now dreadfully lonely
dreadfully lonely
and that isolation begets isolation and
when you get isolated your brain goes
back to the old mechanisms that keep it
safe
and for your husband that is get away
from me
and for you it's whatever it happens to
be
if you if you feel
so unattractive and so sexy coming on to
him
that also has ramifications about how he
makes you feel you see what I'm saying
you just get into this weird dance and
now we're off to the races
and you're both racing on different
tracks you end up way far away okay
when's the last time you all sat down
and exhaled
and said okay we had a plan we had a
two-year plan
we've done it for a year and a quarter
and I don't know if we're gonna make the
rest of the plan can we alternate can we
change something up can we reconsider
can we fill in the blank when's the last
time y'all sat down and said I miss you
I miss your body on my body I missed
being with you I mean right when's the
last time you've had that conversation
uh within the week I mean we have those
conversations regularly okay and what is
his response
I feel trash it's
what's more important than our
relationship is that both of our
daughters who are both seniors in high
school their lives don't get disrupted
disagree totally disagree you know why
because their lives are completely
disregarded I mean disrupted because
their parents
are an anxious wreck right now
never looked at it that way before they
are absorbing both of y'all's tension
and both of your loneliness which turns
into for many parents turns into
neediness and your kids find themselves
propping you guys up which they can't do
and that turns into them saying stupid
stuff like I hate you or get away from
me I don't want to talk to you which
they really do but they their bodies are
saying I can't carry this it's this
adult
they're disrupted they're disrupted
and so that that ship has left the
harbor the question is what can you
provide then the greatest gift you can
give those two girls is a picture of
what a healthy marriage looks like the
great and I'm not saying you have to
live together you're already in this
thing you're 200 days away right it's
almost to the end here
right
but four or five days out of a month
isn't cutting it
it's just not working
and on top of it
I I'm gonna say something that I'm not
certain of okay but I wonder after a a
marriage three kids a whole I wonder how
much you are struggling with his
childhood sexual abuse
more than him
yeah that's I think this is old news for
him yeah it happened that I have just
started struggling with yes you're
exactly right why are you struggling
with it foreign
okay this is why I just realized it
when we have time together and he
reaches over for me
all that goes through my head is he's
only doing this because he knows I need
it that's bull crap [ __ ] you know it
though because he wants me why do you
tell this this has nothing to do with
his child abuse this has to do with you
where did that story come from that
you're not beautiful that when you come
on to your husband and you just want to
ravage out like that you're a man and
you're gross where does that story come
from
probably you know no no hold on don't
probably you know exactly where it comes
from Shay you know exactly where it
comes okay well I don't know if this is
if this is the right answer but there's
no wrong answer but you know where it
comes from
I had
a great childhood I was an only child
for the majority of my life and um
but looking that after I read your book
looking back on the reality I was one of
these people I had the perfect life I
had the perfect life and looking back I
was like wait a minute I've never had a
mother for the first 13 years of my life
my mom I always had to be the mother to
my mom my mom was very driven by her
appearance and her and her sex drive
everything was about her appearance you
know she got a facelift at the age of
40. she left my father and I when I was
13 to live to to move half to move
across the country with my dad's best
friend
and just abandoned us and you know so
listen do you hear that you hear it
though
for your
how that got turned into at a great
childhood is madness
it's bad it's the stories we tell right
it's how we get through the day it's all
good but here's the deal
you've been carrying other adults your
entire life you've been somebody's Mom
since the day you were born
and when it comes to sex you just want
to be able to let go
and so you can blame him
his father the evils of sexual abuse
which will rear its ugly head throughout
your relationship there's no question
about that
but you have to take ownership of the
story that when he reaches for you it's
not really it's it's perfunctory it's a
it's a job it's not because he's all
about you
because you're not all about you
and that's why you can't get through
Emily's book
because that book tells women to
celebrate their bodies
and how their bodies actually work and
what sex in a rambunctious marriage can
actually be like
and you don't believe it am I right
yeah because
you're right because I kind of got mad
at the book yes because that book oh man
and it's not just because of the zipper
vagina yeah it's a terrible yeah I would
not have done that I don't know Emily
I've never met her I've never talked to
her in my life I would be like I see
what you did there right so yes but
listen that's why you didn't like the
book because the book called you out
you are lonely as bloody hell sister
and you are craving touch and that is
butting up against a little girl
who has been told since you were zero
that you are not beautiful you are not
enough and God help me if I turn into my
mom
and you don't deserve that and your
husband doesn't deserve that
and by the way your daughter doesn't
deserve that either
is it possible that in an effort to not
be like your mom you turn the whole
faucet off
and you're dying to thirst
yeah I mean
I mean okay so here I'm going to run
through a couple of things here okay I
um Jenna had let me know just she gave
me a couple of sentences about this call
before so I made a couple of notes here
it's gone a different direction than I
thought it was but here's a couple of
things I'm gonna give you it's just
tactically okay
is that cool
yes please okay
first thing here is
both of you are gonna have to
practice not disconnecting during sex
when I say disconnecting your head
starts going he doesn't even want to be
doing this he doesn't even like this I'm
gross I need to turn this way so he
can't see me in this particular light
you got to stop that you're gonna have
to quit right
yes okay and he's gonna have to practice
when the shame demons come
and I my I've never been sexually abused
by my father right but those men I've
talked to it sounds like the shame
Shadow is is is concrete it's so heavy
right that blanket of Shame he's gonna
have to practice not disconnecting
which also means both of you are going
to find yourselves in the middle of sex
and one of you is going to tap out and
say I gotta stop
and then you're gonna have to figure out
what to do that extra energy and here's
an idea well I gotta be careful
it may be well let's see here that you
come up with alternative ways to dispel
the energy in their presence is that
fair and that gives somebody an
opportunity
to be in the Sexual Energy presence of
their spouse and
not feel like they have to participate
in their bodies taken over for them what
I'm saying is you're going to have to
practice putting yourselves in awkward
situations
and you have to keep going
and when your body starts to feel ugly
you're gonna have to challenge that
story
that's the only way through it you
cannot think your way through this
does that sound scary
foreign
but it brings up this question okay what
is the question I have
I don't know
specific details of his abuse and this
sounds so dumb when it's I'm saying it
out loud but I'm gonna say it anyway I
have this
I feel like I need to know the details
of his abuse so that I can avoid those
things because I feel like different
details don't take that from him
and what does that mean don't take that
like just let him deal with that
is that what you mean like I shouldn't
even be thinking about that he needs to
tell you his needs
do you think about his ex-wife having
when you're having sex with him
no then why would you think about his
childhood
that's your hang up and he doesn't need
you to protect him you're not his mom
you've been your mom's mom you've been
your dad's mom you're not his mom you're
his wife
and may it may be a conversation about
safety where you are honest with them
and you say
I realize I have more Hang-Ups than you
and I'm sorry
I've made your story my story and it's
not fair
and I need you to tell me
that if you're ever uncomfortable you
will say you're uncomfortable because
you feel it when he's uncomfortable
and or you perceive it that he's
uncomfortable and then that sends you
off spinning and you don't come back for
days and since y'all can't see each
other and you don't bump into each other
and you don't hug each other while
you're and accidentally get junk on each
other when you're brushing teeth or
whatever since you don't have that those
moments it's just you alone making up
stories
is that fair yes
and so hey you'll let me know if I ever
cross a line and you feel like
your your child self it comes out to
protect you during sex comes back you'll
let me know and he'll probably look at
you and say yes I'll let you know
now take your clothes off that's
probably what I was gonna say right
that is so freeing like you're not as
Mom you can't control it you can't
control it he's got to be a grown-up and
tell you I need to stop and then you
could have a plan for okay he told me to
stop it's not because I'm ugly it's not
because I'm a man it's because his
body's getting a little bit overwhelmed
so I'm gonna take care of business right
here and we've already talked about this
is that fair
yeah would it be fair for now I'm a very
structured spreadsheet oriented
dork and I live and die by spreadsheets
and but would it be fair
are ridiculous for us to together
establish rules like absolutely every
time we're together we should there's
there's a that's that's practice right a
good coach has practice outlined
for for before they go to practice you
can't just have a coach being like let's
do uh shooting drills Let's uh let's do
free throw you can't do that we're all
the practice is working towards an end
goal right
that's why you have agendas before
meetings I will also tell you you've got
to make space inside you can't have
Reckless and free and wild sex with your
husband if it all comes out of a
spreadsheet
I know right and so but you can you can
have in a spreadsheet we are gonna We
Are Gonna practice intimacy on these
days
and I do have couples pushbacks like man
if I start having to put sex on the
calendar it's not it's not good anymore
that's stupid that's Hollywood bullcrap
it's great
it's just different
you don't schedule it doesn't happen
when we live together we had that we
have that rule like once every week we
each had to initiate once and honestly
that was the best time of our marriage
with that yes okay here I'm gonna give
you um you may have heard this on the
show I think maybe I did it a live event
I was kind of kidding not really I
wasn't I wasn't kidding but
it's not a product that exists okay
here's my here's my recommendation to
you
I'm going to teach you the secrets of
the John Delaney erotic envelope system
it doesn't really exist but that's just
what I call it I want you to go to
Walgreens and get five and ten envelopes
it's going to cost you a grand total of
11 cents or something like that
I want you to give your husband five of
these give your husband ten of these and
you take five and you take ten and
inside of them I want you to take a
scrap of paper and write down whatever
you think
whatever you want we're gonna do this
we're gonna try that we're gonna try
this
and the commitment both of you have is
we're going to randomly draw one we're
gonna pull it out of the drawer once
once a week once a month once every
other day I don't care do it as much as
you want and we commit to doing
whatever's on that card
and sometimes it's like french kissing
what in the world that's just that's it
that's what we're doing we're gonna hold
hands of French kiss you know what we're
gonna do we're gonna sell the front
portions hug
and he can get all bent out of shape
that's what was on the card and then
there may be another card but you're
like I don't know how that's physically
possible but we're willing to either a
go for it or B we're going to talk about
it and I I've heard from couples all
over often the talking about it the
Curiosity
is not the oh gross I'm not doing that
it's
okay
um tell me about this what is it about
this that makes you be like I'm gonna
try that or this sounds like it would be
awesome any number like and be willing
to give that a whirl and now it's got
structure now it's from the envelope
it's not this awkward the awkwardness
gets channeled into this third neutral
object right not us and it gives us a
way to practice gives us inner ways to
enter into this this uncomfortable space
but back it all the way out okay as we
wrap up this call Shay number one
this distance is killing you y'all got
to figure something else out whether you
got to just keep driving a crummy car
and fly on a weekend for rendezvous
y'all gonna meet halfway I don't care
what it is y'all got to figure out
something with this time second thing is
wrecking your marriage or starving your
marriage is not helping your daughters
it's just not okay it's not it's not
it's not I don't know what it looks like
for y'all individually we'd have to have
a bunch more sessions together to figure
that out but it's not it's not helping
it the third thing is
you may have more hang up with his
sexual past than he does his abuse his
whatever
so
you make a commitment I'm not going to
disconnect during sex and ask him make
the commitment to not disconnect and if
you got to we got to talk about it the
fourth thing is practice the
recklessness practice the laughter
practice the all right let's give this
to the world and there's gonna be
disaster when you practice you miss
shots a lot of them right you throw it
past and it goes out into off the wall
or into the stands that's a cool
practice and know that while we're
practicing it's not gonna be because I'm
an idiot or I'm unattractive I'm not
beautiful Etc and my sister Shay I love
you and I'm so proud of you and you're
being brave and courageous thank you for
telling your story
it's time for you to stop being
everybody's mom
and I think you would be well served to
go sit with a counselor and say I need
to learn to love myself because I'm
worth being loved
you're worth being loved okay thank you
so so much we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the house work it is right now
and how powerless home buyers feel mix
that with the stress of moving and life
change and job change and you've got a
tornado of anxiety fueling one of the
biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement and MLS ID 1591 in MLS
consumeraccess.org Equal Housing lender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and not available in all
states or locations
all right we're back let's go to Renee
in canoxville Knoxville Tennessee what's
up Renee
hi what's up
nothing much how are you pretty good
pretty good what's happening how can I
help
um
alcoholic in it okay I'm so happy he's
in rehab
but I have times where I am just so
depressed
not because he's in I'm I love that he's
in rehab and I love that he is trying
I'm so proud of him but I get into where
I'm just I don't know what to do to get
out of the depression can I ask you a
hard question
yes
are you mad at him too
with what we've went through yes nope
nope nope nope nope are you mad at him
too
let me say this it's a trick question I
know you are just say it out loud
are you frustrated and sad
yes are you broken-hearted
yes did you have this awesome picture of
the way your life was going to be at
your age and it looks nothing like it
and you're sitting alone while your
husband's in rehab
yes
all of those things get pushed lower and
lower and lower
some would call them getting compressed
another word for compress is to depress
and if you're not honest about what your
body is feeling
your body will hide it but it will
they'll still be there and they will
Poison every part of your spirit and
every part of your life
you gotta be honest about them
well I didn't feel it until after
um
the rehab one of me to write this letter
yep about what we went through
and before I did that I went through
some soul-searching myself while he's in
rehab and I felt like I was doing good
I was like okay I've gotten through this
and then they tell me to write the
letter
and since then it's been like
I'm constantly thinking about everything
we went through again that's right
and let me tell you this the alcoholism
is a context not an excuse
yes he shouldn't have cheated on you he
shouldn't eat cussed at you he shouldn't
have swung at you and I'm just making
things up he may have done none of those
things
but all those things that happen should
not have happened they were still abused
they were still wrong they were still
painful and still hurtful
and it can be both and
you can be enraged to the man you love
Trilogy like that
and you can be heartbroken that he's
sick
and you can be disgusted and thinking
about not wanting to be married to him
anymore and be really at peace that he's
in rehab
the depression the exhaustion you feel
that existent like the I don't you wanna
I don't want to eat I don't get up
it's your body trying to force you to
live in one of those extremes without
accepting the tension that is
and you're trying to think your way into
peace and you can't you got to act
that's why with them asking you to do
something like write a letter was so
good and I would ask you to write
another one and another one after that
because it's gonna it's like
man when you pull that bandage off and
rip the scab off that sucker is infected
and it's gonna bleed and bleed and bleed
and you gotta let it go
but that's scary for you why is that
scary
because I've always been the one who had
to
keep control of my emotions
because even when my parents passed away
I I had to keep the smile on my face and
for my kids no you didn't no you didn't
you chose to that was a choice you
didn't have it it's just the way I felt
because I thought it
that's right and you know I'm not trying
to shame you the greatest gift you could
give your kids is to show them that
you're upset
it's the greatest gift you can give your
children
other than a great marriage and here's
why because when your parents died they
got really really sad
yes and they looked at mom who was still
smiling and they go on to think they're
crazy
but when Mom says I'm so sad I'm crying
my eyes out by myself we all come sit
with me because I miss my mommy I miss
my dad
it makes your kids feel not nuts
it makes them feel whole
see what I'm saying
if your husband's off at rehab and
you're just being a good old southern
Knoxville mama and you are cleaning
things up and making sure everything's
not Dusty
they're going to think that their parent
isn't is a animatron is a robot
and they're going to feel insane and in
many ways you feel that way too don't
you
yes
because I can be happy one minute and
then the next I'm just wanting to fall
apart and scream and in counseling we
call it leakage and I know it's a
terrible way to say it you can deal with
those emotions or they will deal with
you and they usually will deal with you
at a real inopportune time when your
margin is the thinnest when you're about
to give a big presentation at work when
you're about to have a hard conversation
with your kids when you get pulled over
when you when one parent looks at you
wrong and you're just like listen here
mother you just go off right
they will come out
and so I think it's much more wiser to
deal with it on my own on my terms in my
safe space with my counselor with my
notebook with my journal whatever that
is with my gym I don't whatever it is I
gotta deal with it because it will deal
with me
no but you are doing your damn well best
to make yourself crazy
you're working hard at it yeah you're
doing good at it
you really are trying hard because I'm
trying because I
and that's beautiful but that's also
that's your drug that's a defense
mechanism for you
that's performative it's playing
what the world really needs is Renee to
be Renee
what you need is a healthy dose of
honesty
or let me say it this way this is a rude
way to say it but I'm just going to be
honest with you
you're every bit the addict your husband
is
yes I agree with that I I'm not an
addict but I'm I you're an addict he's
an addict to alcohol you're an addict
too
control
you're an addict to Performance you're
an attitude making sure everybody else
is at peace and even I'll die on that
altar but as long as everybody there's
no one can see a ripple in the water and
the sheets are straight at the edge of
this bed we're all good
okay is that fair yeah
I just want yeah I want everybody to be
because I'll do whatever
I know but you sacrifice your happiness
to try to make other people happy and
they feel they know that you're not
happy and that makes that keeps them
from ever having Joy
the greatest gift you can give somebody
else is
you
foreign
is you've probably been peacekeeping for
a long long time is that fair
I can so you're gonna go through a
season of practicing
of saying what you actually think
and then when that guilt wave comes over
you like a tsunami you gotta just sit
take it
someone's going to ask you hey could you
make all the pies like you did last year
for the thing and you're gonna say
you're not even gonna give an excuse
you're going to say no
um not this year thank you so much for
the invitation
and that's it that's all you're going to
say
you don't owe them any like well I just
can't because I've well I've got you
know anybody an explanation
you can just say no and then when you do
that your body will feel like shame and
loser and I'm the worst in it and you're
gonna have to just for the first time
feel it
and probably have somebody with you
feeling it
writing it down
because it's going to all be new
it's going to all be new
but when it comes to
feeling those feelings the next logical
step when you actually feel them becomes
boundaries
you will not drink in my home
you will not talk to me or my kids this
way
you will not take our money and spend it
you will not sleep with other people
when we're married like or whatever your
boundaries happen to be and for your
particular situation with your husband
but here's the thing it's completely
normal to feel chaos and feelings and I
feel this but I also feel this I can't
be around this person but I still love
them I love this person but they're not
the right person for me to marry I'm so
grateful this person's in rehab and I'm
so ticked off that they screwed up
everything
that's adulthood it's being able to
handle the tension
but I want to put your husband's
Addiction on the side and I want you to
get in touch with Renee for the first
time in your whole life
what you feel what you think and scary
and frighteningly what do you actually
want you get one shot of this little
crazy life we got what do you want
what do you want
whatever it is you you you can go get it
you can go get it we'll be right back
all right we're back let's take uno mas
let's go to Justin in Green Bay what's
up Justin
uh not much on my lunch break talking to
you dude that's pretty rad way to go man
your lunch break
well when you punch in at four in the
morning ah I see what you did there
you're one of those guys that worked
hard for a living what's that like is
that is that cool
well two jobs going to school for
mechanical engineering yeah I'm kind of
going all the time bro you're getting it
man so what's up
um I'm having problems with my I'm
raising my 12 year old daughter by
myself since she was five uh whatever
mom decided
um her mom just kind of decided she
couldn't be a mom oh man um she still
has visitation
but it's rare like maybe once or twice a
year um she lives over in Detroit now
um and actually that comes back to it
when we were just over there two three
weeks ago she talked to her mom to talk
to me because she wanted an iPhone
and it's a question she's brought up
before and I told her no you don't need
an iPhone you don't even need a phone
phone but I need to get a hold of you
sometimes so talk text take pictures
that's all it's good for
um
and I asked her kind of
why did you go to your mom she's like
well I don't want you to get mad at me
well I'm not gonna get mad at you you
just ask and I say no
and she did it again with another friend
of mine went to her and then had her
come with her so she could quit
gymnastics
um she's been in it for seven years
and she's very very good she's just
struggling because she's at a new level
where they're harder on her they're kind
of pushing her
and she's not taking to it well plus
she's a pre-teen
so I don't know what to do with her
going to other people saying I'll get
mad at her when it's just I tell her no
and I tell her why and it's like she
doesn't like the answer
hmm
do you get frustrated
less than I used to I used to be kind of
angry everything was thrown on me
um after the custody I almost lost my
house I had to fight to hang on to that
um I'm coming out of the that's why I'm
going to school
I don't yell at her anymore
um I used to
um one thing you said a long time ago
was yelling is trauma and that kind of
Hit me hard because I grew up in a
household where I got yelled at a lot
yeah
so I stopped yelling I do get frustrated
because she's 12. 12 year old kid yeah I
got one too and yeah the frustrating is
part of the game
um
have you dealt with the fact that your
wife looked at you and said I'd Rather
Have Nothing than you
foreign
I have her and I actually get along very
well now
um that's fine you've made peace with
that have you dealt with that
I think so okay where does your rage
still come from
because here's the thing that a lot of
dads do
we quit yelling
we quit hitting the wall
but we don't deal with the rage
and it just sits in our chest like a
nuclear reactor and our kids absorb it
they breathe it
and so we trade we stopped an overtly
abusive Behavior which is great
so we are not a place for a child to
come rest
what I see your daughter doing is
actually really healthy she's trying to
connect with you and her body's telling
her that you're not safe
not because you're saying no I tell my
kids no all the time
all the time
my guess is she's put a GPS pin and this
guy used to yell this guy her body has
created an ecosystem where you're not
safe in it
have you ever taken her out for
breakfast and said I used to yell out
I'm so sorry I'm never gonna eat it
again
actually do that a lot I apologize she
she says I know you don't yell you raise
your voice when you need to but you
don't yell awesome you're not angry
she you know I
tell her I love her she says she loves
me back she talks to me about everything
when she comes home from four hours of
gymnastics she's just comes home from
school and talks to me talks to me about
her friends and all that but it seems
like the things that I
say no to
it's almost like I'm
she's trying to get somebody else to get
on her side ah dude you know who did
that probably your wife
your daughter's 12. yeah she's just
pushing boundaries to see if they're
gonna hold
I would lose one second of sleep of that
in fact that's pretty admirable because
here's why
um you told your kid no you gave her a
reason
she uh didn't go in her room and slam
the door she wouldn't found another
person to talk about how she feels
that's the that's the Baseline for being
well is having other people right it's
awesome yeah and yeah it's up to you to
not get emotionally reactive when she
comes at you with three of her friends
and say Here's why she should have a
phone and you can smile and say y'all
are really brilliant we'll do ice cream
but no phones well played or I'll even
tell my son he'll be like hey Dad on the
way home let's just go ahead and get ice
cream because and I'll just look at him
and go well played man no chance and he
just like I'm not gonna get mad at 12
year old for being 12 year old yeah and
this is hard because you've been her
everything because you had to be and
you're a good man
but you can't be her everything forever
one of the greatest gifts my dad gave me
um I was a young kid and he was a he was
a homicide detective and then literally
over a weekend he quit and became a
minister at a big giant Church in
Houston
and he said this to me and I didn't get
how big of a deal it was until I got
older but he said you are never going to
be able to hear about your our faith
from me anymore I'm your minister now
and I'm also your dad you're not going
to listen
please find other men in this building
that you can trust
who will speak life into you and at the
time I was a kid I was like okay
whatever dude guys who cares what dad
say dads are morons right
um
when you're when you're 12 or 14. and
now that I'm older to think about my
kids and and now I'm hyperintentional
dude you find other people you talk to
that person you talk to that person I
love it I think it's great
it's it's not a you're you're putting
adult uh what's the you're putting adult
thoughts and feelings and motives into
the heart and mind of a 12 year old
is that fair
do y'all sit down and talk about hard
stuff like boys and periods and stuff
[Music]
[Laughter]
she she kind of floored me with the
first boyfriend while we were cleaning
her room one day so that was fun
dude that's so good that she trusts you
man
just kind of walked away for a second
why
because I was I was so afraid of that
coming up being a single dad raising a
girl and knowing what little
butt heads little boys can be
even the good ones are turds man
um
it's so great that she felt safe enough
to do that with you
that's awesome
and it's it's also
like
you have an incredibly important role in
her life
and that's to tell her that she's
beautiful and that she's brilliant
and if she she'll allow it don't force
it but if she'll allow it to put your
hands on her face as often as possible
put your hands on the back of her neck
underneath her hair as often as possible
hug her as often as possible you don't
have to say anything
yeah
that's something I've very much tried to
do so I give her a hug I tell her she's
wonderful she's smart she's talented
she's funny and I get that smile yes and
I feel she hears me and I just watch her
lighten up and it makes my entire day
yes
and can I tell you one other thing to
balance
not saying this is you at all it's just
a common thing for folks who have
experienced what you've experienced is
that 12 year old will take on rightly or
wrongly
they'll take on making sure dad's okay
that's not her job and don't never let
her fall into that role that I gotta
make sure dad's not mad I gotta make
sure dad's happy I gotta make sure
because she can't carry that she's still
trying to figure out what she did that
was so bad that Mom left her
and that demon will haunt her for years
right
I know I I she's the first couple years
are very hard
um when we left last time she started
crying but she kind of got over it quick
it's
after almost eight years just kind of
I don't want to say she accepts that she
hates it but
she kind of knows how it is and I see it
hurt her and I try and do everything I'm
at every gymnastics meets when she was
in bowling league I was there all the
time when she tried softball I was at
every game I ended up coaching so so let
her find her path
letter finder met her own road map
and
um there's a fine balance and I think we
did a Show recently about that there's a
fine balance between I'm going to make
you keep going until the season's over
till the support until this season is
over of this
um but if we if you're done at the end
I'll honor that but you're going to do
something you have to do something right
I gave her that good for you good for
you I gave her that you can be done at
the end of the season and but you will
be doing other stuff you will not be
sitting at home there you go that's good
to hear about it every summer I don't
want to practice oh but two weeks in I
did this I did that okay and that's just
being a dad good for you for not letting
a 12 year old's feelings run your
household that's awesome hey can I tell
you sounds like you're doing a great job
man
thank you I I worry a lot it's not easy
that's right none of this is easy
um
I yeah dude parenting is just sprinting
across a live wire without a net and
then with people shooting at you just
for fun right you're doing a great
you're doing a great job
and I I I bucket a great job like
um I care about my kid I bucket a great
job like
um
I've got things I got to work on so I'm
gonna stop doing those things I'm gonna
keep working on those things
um and I'm Gonna Keep seeking wisdom man
and you're doing all three of those
things I'm and so I'm just grateful for
you here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
send you all the questions for humans
cards okay and all right set up a reg
here's what we're looking for
we're not looking for the perfect
boyfriend conversation
we're not looking for the just the right
pamphlet that's going to let us sit down
and talk about periods because Mom is
not around
we're looking to create an environment
where she feels so safe she can have
those conversations
and it sounds like y'all are there
as I just upped the ante with my 12 year
old
and I did something as much as
um make a list of the movies I wanted to
see before he he's gone here's a list of
things I want him to have done
whether that's change a tire tie a tie
you know dress a deer like whatever I
got some Texas things in there I gotta
have but what like what are these things
that I want to be a part of with him
that I can be intentional about and one
of those is just being able to have a
conversation and enjoy the silence and
so I'll send you all the cards man and
set up a regular breakfast with your
kids up a regular dinner take her on a
date once a week whatever that is and
instead of talking bad about the boys
they're gonna be dating her someday
let her experience
[Music]
okay that boy is some knuckleheaded
idiot at middle school or high school
kid is gonna have to he already broke up
with her for no reason so I heard about
that too
well I know people we can find him we
can find him no but listen you want to
build you want to her to feel so safe
with you and so loved and so beautiful
and so brilliant when y'all are out on
your dates that some knuckleheaded high
school kid doesn't stand a chance
doesn't have a chance
she's look at his stringy mustache and
his mom's used Camry and just be like
what in the world I'd really go to a
movie with my dad he's funnier and he's
cooler
and he's got way more money than this
kid
right you want someone's gonna have to
really be special
and we're building a relationship there
I'd also encourage her
to have some adult women in her life
that are in your area that you trust
maybe from like school or from your
local church or whatever wherever you
get connected
and encourage her to make relationships
there
[Music]
encourage her to have people to talk to
that may not be you the conversation
might go like I know you get nervous
sometimes around me talk to somebody I
would love you to talk to me
but rather you talk to somebody than
talk to nobody right and if you help
curate some of those relationships
um man that gives your kid just an
entire safety net of people who love her
but man you've you're making the best of
a messy situation brother and I'm
honored to be a fellow dad with you on
this wild Journey we're on man
congratulations we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show the
the
mighty and great
salt and pepper wrote an incredible song
Back in the Day guys to love them
um songs called Let's Talk About Sex and
it goes like this
let's talk about sex baby let's talk
about you and me let's talk about all
the good things and bad things it may be
Let's Talk About Sex not for now to the
people at home or in the crowd it keeps
coming up anyhow don't decoy avoid or
make void the topic cause ain't gonna
stop it now we talk about sex on the
radio and video shows many will know
anything goes let's tell it how it is
and how it could be how it was and of
course how it should be
guess that's what we do here right here
we'll see you soon
[Music]